Just like with the superhero Batman, we've
seen quite a few versions of Catwoman, also
known as Selina Kyle, over the years.
From Julie Newmar and Eartha Kitt in the "Batman"
TV series starring Adam West and Burt Ward,
to Michelle Pfeiffer and Anne Hathaway in
more modern film adaptations, there have been
many changes to the character over time.
So when it was announced that Zoë Kravitz
would be taking on the iconic character for
the new "The Batman" movie, fans should've
known to expect something new.
In "The Batman," fans get to see a younger
Bruce Wayne, played by Robert Pattinson, in
his early years as the vigilante, and that's
the same case with Selina.
She isn't quite Catwoman yet, though she's
well on her way.
While she has all of the skills and the drive
to become the well-known antihero, she's still
just a young woman with some personal issues
to take care of.
But what else does the 2022 film change about
Selina?
While there are a few stark changes to the
character to note with Kravitz's performance,
there's one glaring difference that drives
the whole movie forward.
Beware: spoilers ahead!
In the original DC "Catwoman" comics, Selina's
parents are Maria and Brian Kyle, who both
tragically die when she is quite young, leading
to her life on the street.
But the version of Selina we see in "The Batman"
doesn't quite have the same experience.
Yes, her mother is Maria, but her father is
someone very different.
It's noted by many that the comics include
speculation that Selina's real parents aren't
the Kyles, but are really Carmine Falcone
and his wife, Louisa.
While the comics never explicitly confirm
or deny this, "The Batman" decides to concretely
change the story and have Falcone be Selina's
father.
In the movie, Maria works at the Iceberg Lounge
and has a relationship of sorts with the mob
boss, which results in Selina's birth.
There is zero mention of her comic book father
Brian, and it seems unlikely that there ever
would be in possible future films.
Selina is completely sure that Falcone is
her father, but after being abandoned by him
after her mother's death (which she later
finds out is his doing), she has no real attachment
to the man, though she holds strong feelings
of resentment and anger.
So when Bruce uncovers the true depth of Falcone's
crimes, Selina is ever so eager to find Falcone
and take him down, stopping him from doing
anything else while also getting a chance
to confront him about her mother.
Add to that the reveal that he's involved
in her roommate's death, and you've got just
about the worst father-daughter relationship
out there.
But aside from the connection with Falcone,
"The Batman" also makes one other small yet
important change to Selina.
While this is a very small detail in the new
movie, longtime fans of Catwoman in the DC
Comics might notice something about the way
Selina interacts with her roommate and coworker
from the Iceberg Lounge.
This detail is actually a change from past
screen depictions of Selina, but it makes
the character more similar to the comic book
version.
Luckily for those who missed it, Matt Galea
of Pedestrian did not, picking up on hints
of an intimate relationship between the two
women, especially in how Selina calls her
"baby."
Selina is frequently depicted as bisexual
in the comics, which is made canon in "Catwoman"
#39.
So while "The Batman" definitely doesn't confirm
Selina's sexuality, there are hints that this
aspect of the character may be explored in
further films.
Galea was able to ask both Kravitz and director
Matt Reeves about this specific detail directly,
and whether or not it was a purposeful choice
in order to highlight her bisexuality in the
comics.
Kravitz confirmed to Galea for Pedestrian
that although it wasn't written in the script,
"That's definitely the way I interpreted that,
that they had some kind of romantic relationship."
Reeves wasn't as definitive with his comments,
but he did say that,
"I don't think we meant to go directly in
that way, but you can interpret it that way
for sure ... there was meant to be quite an
intimate relationship between them."
Based on this, it's certainly worth having
hope that — if Reeves, Kravitz, and others
return for future installments after "The
Batman" — Selina's sexuality will finally
be accurately presented on screen.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about “The
Batman” are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.